[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hi, and welcome to
Serverless Migration Station,
where we show Google
Cloud users one
step they can take to modernize
their serverless apps.
I'm Wesley, joined
by my colleague
Martin and our little friend
Porter to take you from point A
to point B.
As a long-time App
Engine developer,
you're probably aware of using
its default database, the App
Engine Datastore, via
its NDB client library.
To make user apps more portable,
the next generation App Engine
service has moved away from
bubble services like Datastore.
Since Datastore has matured
into its own product, Cloud
Datastore, we're
here to help you
take the key step of migrating
from App Engine's and NDB
to Cloud NDB so your app can
basically use the same NDB
code, but accessing
Cloud Datastore instead.
MARTIN: My app uses
Datastore quite a bit,
so I'm interested in this.
How do I get started
with this migration, Wes?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, in the
previous video for module 1,
we migrated our base LAN webapp2
NDB Datastore app to Flask,
a popular framework in
the Python community.
Today we pick up right
where module 1 left off,
a Flask NDB Datastore app.
And we're going to migrate that
to a Flask Cloud NDB Datastore
app.
MARTIN: Ah, yes.
I remember that migration.
But I forgot where
the module 1 code is.
Can you point me to it again?
WESLEY CHUN: Definitely, Martin.
So go to the Migration
Module video, and clone it
or download the zip file.
Its link is also in the
video description below.
We'll start with the module 1
code, perform the NDB migration
steps, and voila, that will
result in the module 2 code.
Since this app uses only
one App Engine service,
after moving to Cloud
NDB, you can easily
port your app to Python 3.
So the code lab that features
that bonus migration.
That's why you'll also find a
pair of module 2 repo folders,
one each for Python 2 and 3.
But hold on, partner.
Let's do the Cloud
NDB migration first.
So hit pause now to go
get the module 1 code.
OK, if you're ready, let's walk
you through this migration.
As in previous
modules, let's ensure
we have a working
app before migrating.
From your model 1 folder, check
you've got Flask in your lib
folder, or run the pip
install command if you don't.
Upload to App Engine
with gcloud app deploy,
then once it's live, point
a browser or curl to it
and confirm the output's
the same for module 0 and 1.
Next, we're ready to migrate to
Cloud NDB, this time starting
with the config files.
Any time you use a Google Cloud
client library in Python 2,
you need a pair of third
party helper libraries.
Fortunately, they're already
on App Engine servers,
so do not add them to
requirements.txt nor use
pip install.
Built-in libraries like this
are declared in app.yaml.
Here, create a new
library section
with grpcio and setuptools.
If your app's app.yaml
has a library section,
and these helper libraries,
if they're not already there.
The good news is that
third party packages
are way easier in
the next gen, where
it's just requirements.txt.
In the module 1
video, we explained
you need to tell
App Engine where
to look for your self bundle or
copied third party libraries.
That's done in
appengine_config.py.
It's also true of built-in
third party libraries,
like grbcio and setuptools,
but requires a different code
snippet in App Engine config,
where you reference them
to lib in the
setuptools.packageresources
working set, just
like you see here.
This App Engine
config can now handle
both built-in and copied
third party libraries.
So this is probably
pretty good boilerplate
to have for all of your
Python 2 App Engine apps.
We mentioned earlier how
third party package management
is way easier in Python 3, and
not even having an App Engine
config file is part of that.
Next are the third
party packages
we do need to copy or bundle.
In module 1, we created
requirements.txt
with a single
reference to Flask.
Now add the Cloud NDB library
spelled google-cloud-ndb, all
lowercase with
hyphens in between.
When making this video,
Flask was on version 1.1.2
and Cloud NDB was on 1.8.0.
Since the repo is
actively maintained,
you may see newer
versions there.
Now delete any
old lib folder you
may have and run the
pip install command
to get those libraries in there
so we can upload to App Engine.
That's it for config.
Let's jump into main.py,
starting with the imports.
It's a one-for-one swap
to switch from App Engine
NDB to Cloud NDB.
As with most Google
Cloud client libraries,
you'd need to create a
client to access the API.
So that's the new line you see.
The best news is that most
of your NDB code stays as is.
The only difference is that
it's more idiomatic Python,
requiring use of the
client's context manager.
If you're new to
those, it's just
saying that you need to acquire
those resources before you
can use them.
You'll typically see with
statements with files,
because you've got to
be able to open a file
before you can read from
or write to it, right?
So add a new with block and
put all of your Datastore calls
inside, like what you see here.
Everything else is
the same, making
this migration fairly painless.
One more tip is that
transactional tasks isn't
a feature in Cloud
NDB yet, meaning you
can't create tasks only if
the transaction succeeds.
In other words, task
queue calls won't
get rolled back if
the transaction fails,
only Datastore operations.
Ignoring the readme, all other
source files stay unchanged.
Index.html template file,
gcloudignore, and really,
that's it.
So that's the entire
migration to Cloud NDB.
Before we go back
to the presentation,
let's talk briefly
about a Python 3 port.
The language updates you have
to make may be considerable.
If there's any good news
on the App Engine side,
it mostly involves
deleting stuff,
like deleting a bunch
of lines from app.yaml,
deleting the lib folder and
appengine_config.py file.
Our super simple app is
already Python 2/3 compatible.
So the only file that
needs updating is app.yaml.
Change the language version.
Now, that's obvious.
Next gen App Engine
requires a web framework
that does its own routing.
So you have three options here.
Set all script handlers to
auto, because the framework
does the routing now.
Two, delete all script handlers,
because if everything is auto,
they're all meaningless, right?
Or three, replace handlers
with an entry point section
if you have specific
startup requirements.
Read more about these
options in the docs.
Note, I only said
script handlers.
Static file handling
stays as is.
Lastly, I've already said
third party package management
in the next gen is way
simpler, allowing you to delete
the library section entirely.
Again, the real work for your
app is the language update.
OK, back to the show.
MARTIN: Wow.
That was a pretty
straightforward migration, Wes.
I'm glad to see most user
code doesn't have to change.
I have one question, though.
What if I have an older
app, say a Python 2.5 app?
The 2.5 runtime was
deprecated in 2013,
and then it was completely
shut down in 2017
when Python 2.7 took over.
So my app's been
dead ever since.
Can I somehow bring
it back to life?
WESLEY CHUN: The
answer is yes, Martin.
But there is a catch.
You have to migrate
from 2.5 to 2.7
and DB to NDB first before
applying the migration we just
discussed.
Check out these Python 2.5
DB docs as well as the NDB
migration guide to get started.
MARTIN: That's great.
Are there docs for NDB too?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, here are
the links to App Engine NDB
as well as its library repo.
We'll also post them in
the description below.
MARTIN: Thanks for those
DB and NDB resources.
Can we round out this trifecta
with the Cloud NDB docs?
And while you're
looking that up, why
is it so important to
migrate to Cloud NDB anyway?
WESLEY CHUN: Of course, Martin.
Here are its library
and its docs links.
As far as why it's
important, you
know that modernizing your app
and making them more portable
is one goal of the latest
App Engine platform.
For Python developers,
the key reason
is that Cloud NDB works in
both Python 2 and 3, which
means that once
you're on Cloud NDB,
you can finally upgrade
your app to Python 3.
And with that, you've crossed
the datastore finish line
literally.
This is the last of the
required migrations,
as far as the Datastore goes.
It's not necessary
to migrate further
to Cloud Datastore's native
client library nor Cloud
Firestore unless you've got
specific reasons to do so.
MARTIN: OK.
What would be some
of the reasons
I'd consider those optional
Datastore migrations?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, using the
official Cloud Datastore client
library means moving away from
everything you know about NDB
and how it works.
The primary reason to
do this is if you have
other apps that already use it.
For example, Python 3 App Engine
apps or non App Engine apps.
And you want to consolidate
so that you're not
using two different
client libraries
to talk to the same Datastore.
It simplifies and reduces
your maintenance costs too.
Anyway, if you want
to look into it,
see the module 3
code lab and video.
The next generation of Cloud
Datastore is Cloud Firestore.
Based on the name
change, you can probably
guess that it now has some
features from the Firebase
Realtime Database.
And you'd be right.
This migration is
for those who must
have some of those Firebase
features for their apps.
Check out module
6, if interested.
MARTIN: OK.
So if those other Datastore
migrations are optional,
where can I go now?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah,
great question, Martin.
Well, users should continue
to migrate from App Engine's
bundled services to standalone
services outside of App Engine,
like Cloud NDB.
What other App Engine services
and APIs are you using?
If you use push task
queues, consider
migrating to Cloud Tasks, and
see module 7 to get started.
If your organization
is consolidating apps
into containers for flexibility,
CI/CD, or consistency,
consider migrating to Cloud Run.
If so see, modules 4 and 5.
Finally, it goes without
saying that porting to Python 3
should always be a
consideration, since Python
2 has been sunset.
We add new migration
modules periodically,
and most will have videos too.
So keep checking back.
MARTIN: Cool.
What other migration resources
do you have for Cloud NDB?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
the best place to look
is in the docs for Cloud NDB,
especially its migration guide.
The code in those
docks has its own repo,
so here's a link to that.
And finally, check
out the last link
that points to migration samples
contributed by the community.
On behalf of Martin and
Porter, this is Wesley Chun.
Thanks for tuning into this
episode of Serverless Migration
Station and allowing us
to show you different ways
to modernize your apps.
And we'll see you the next
time on another Serverless
Expeditions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]